why do you say movies are like real
estate because movies are property
movies are intellectual property and
okay let's let's take a simple idea
right let's take a a house and cost you
a hundred thousand dollars right
might not be able to get a hundred
thousand dollars not a house here
but let's take a house that costs a
hundred thousand and you take a movie
that costs a hundred thousand right
so both of these properties
one is a physical property both are
physical but one is a a a property that
is actually on land and this property
lives now in the world that we live in
in a digital world right
so you take both of these properties and
the idea of both of them is what the
house is evil to either you're gonna
flip this property
and you're gonna just sell it you buy
four hundred thousand put a fifty
thousand into it sell it for three
hundred thousand same thing with the
movie either you're gonna you make the
movie 100 Grand sell it for 300 Grand or
you take both of these properties and
you keep them over time
and you just let them pay you residuals
so in the real estate world we call it
um a portfolio
a housing portfolio
sure I'm sure there's other terms
and then the the film War we call it a
catalog or a film slate right so both of
them perform
they might not perform the same and what
I found is that my real estate I'm
Excuse me my my film
um
um films perform
better than a lot of real estate that
I've been involved with
so
um that's just an analogy that I came up
with right and I mean it's it's or a
formula whatever you want to call it
it's it's something that I've come up
with to be able to equate
um to look at the two businesses and
compare
you know and I think that overall
the overall goal is with which to for
you to figure out am I just selling
these properties am I building them to
sell them or am I building them to get
residuals
whether buyer and seller markets for
films you know how you know ups and
downs in the real estate market whether
commercial or residential are there are
there Peaks and valleys for uh selling
films
um I don't think that the Peaks and
valleys for selling films are
probably bad as of real estate because
entertainment you know everybody wants
to be entertained I mean you you're
gonna always you know be able to sell a
movie if that's what you if that's what
you're looking to do with that movie if
this company doesn't want it another
company might want it if they don't want
it somebody else might want it if that's
not the case you can always go make
money off of it and self-distribute and
do it yourself right
so I think that you know that in that
part of the business is is it it differs
because I mean you're talking
you're talking uh there's two different
Industries two different regulate
regulatory situations and whatnot does
money really matter I mean isn't telling
the story The most important thing
when it comes to a film
yes well
um I mean that that right there is is a
question for each individual because it
depends on
you know try telling that to Sony
try telling Sonia or um
or Paramount that money really doesn't
matter right so from a business
standpoint
I think that you have to find a balance
in both of them right you want to tell a
good story
right and and okay
as a producer I'm extremely passionate
about creating these movies
but
also while I'm creating these films I
have to be mindful of the performance of
what they could potentially do and what
they could potentially not do right so
as a producer that's one of the hats
that you that you wear on set that a lot
of people wouldn't understand
particularly the actors
and sometimes other crew members because
as a EP executive producer that means
that if this film does not perform well
you're the only one taking the hit
right so everybody else still gets paid
everybody else get paid so
um the only person that's going to take
that loss is you now of course
creatively an artist wants to an actor
actress they want to be a part of a
product that is successful
of course that that's you know they they
you know especially if it's someone who
has a lot of skin in the game they got a
nice portfolio films out they want to be
associated with things that are
perceived to be good
so
ultimately
yes I'm sure they want the product to
succeed but if it doesn't if it flops
then they just gonna go make another
movie as a producer
if you didn't if you didn't map your
situation out the right way who knows
you might not be making one for a while
right so I think that
I think that
um that you have to find that meeting
that that that that that spot that that
that that uh Central spot
to uh figure out
how to find that balance how do I tell a
a great quality film
um without going over budget
of whatever that budget is that you set
and without
compromising by not going over the
budget or not having such high above
budget how do you not compromise the
quality of of that film
and what is mailbox money
mailbox money is money that you have
coming in
that you've set up to
to just flow
is that's residuals that's um
that's that's that's you having a
catalog of movies
and these films making you making you
money every day and you'll see in your
sleep because if you think about it
you know any film that you have out
there like it's somebody right there
watching somebody's around here
somewhere right now watching all my
movies right so those films and that
goes for any filmmaker those films are
generating money even when you're not
working on them anymore
so you put this film out you look up
five six seven ten years later and it's
still generate money
um that's mailbox money Ramon who taught
you about business
um well I learned about business early
on from my dad
um you know he's asked me when I was a I
was a kid he used to ask me what do you
want to be when you grow up and I'd be
like you know what I want to be a
businessman
I didn't know what that was but I knew
he was a businessman because he used to
have briefcases and all of this stuff
and it wasn't even so much as that it
was just the way he carried himself you
um I always understood that my dad was a
very calculated person who
was
business savvy just by you know the way
he conducted himself
and I mean you know as a kid you you
you're gonna aspire to those around you
so you know early on that was my initial
um
I guess
introduction to
what business was
and then
um later on and later on I I have many
teachers you know I have many teachers
along the way
um in a lot of areas of business
um I'm self-taught
um you know a lot of you know a lot of
just me bumping my head against the wall
and and throwing things against the wall
and seeing if it sticks
doing a lot of reading a lot of research
trying things
um
you know just just putting myself out
there so
I would say you know ultimately the
teacher of it is it would be me just
just um
getting out there and figuring it out
has your dad gone to screenings of your
films uh actually actually my dad
invests in me and him partner up on a
bunch of my projects
and so his company is
mil Max films and I'm Swift Motion
Pictures
yeah so um he he he's been supportive
since the beginning you know and um and
I'm glad that we're able to now
you know do some business together